le
c'est une petite ville de bord de mer
comme on les aime
avec ces bateaux blancs ces maisons de
bardos et son clocher de bois pendant
les beaux jours d'été la population de
belfast peu passée de 7000 à plus de
10000 habitants
il y a aussi une clinique de planning
familial ouvert à l'année
c'est l'endroit où travaillent giuly
jenkins cette infirmière est spécialisée
en santé reproductive contraception
traitements hormonaux et interruptions
de grossesse elle est très connue pour
son implication dans ce dossier et
réclame l'élargissement de l'accès à
l'avortement
axa ce matin là des jeunes patientes
viennent pour obtenir des soins et des
conseils sur la contraception
cette mère de deux enfants explique
qu'elle n'aurait pas les moyens dans la
voir un troisième et elle est inquiète
le retour à l'avant-scène du débat sur
l'avortement lui fait craindre le pire
le maine est un état plutôt conservateur
à la législature locale le poste de
gouverneur a longtemps été détenu par un
républicain
mais depuis les dernières élections les
démocrates détiennent la majorité des
deux chambres et le poste de gouverneur
la représentante démocrate jamie wright
a réussi à faire adopter malgré
l'opposition des républicains et de
certains élus de son propre camp une loi
qui oblige les compagnies d'assurance
privées à rembourser les frais
d'avortement
cette loi prévoit aussi le financement
public des avortements pour les
personnes démunies
l'espérance et cette question de justice
en matière de procréation
djouhri jenkins y est confronté à tous
les jours une partie importante de sa
clientèle n'a pas accès à une assurance
médicale et ni à la mi journée giuly
jenkins apprend qu'une nouvelle patiente
viendra plus tard pour subir un
avortement
la démarche est intime délicate souvent
déchirante mais l'infirmière devra aussi
discuté de la question financière avec
elle
l'autre revendication centrale des
infirmières spécialisées et des
associations de santé pour les femmes
c'est la proximité géographique du
personnel médical compétent
cette jeune femme qui tient à rester
anonyme en est à sa sixième semaine de
grossesse l'avortement pourra donc être
déclenchée par une simple prise de
médicaments dans le maine l'avortement
est permis mais rigoureusement encadré
[Musique]
c'est un acte médical qui doit être
supervisé par un médecin mais sa
participation est minimale la
communication se fait par
vidéoconférence son rôle se limite à
regarder la patiente avaler le comprimé
une obligation légale que conteste giuly
jenkins devant les tribunaux surtout que
99% du travail est fait par les
infirmières spécialisées comme elle
la question était finalement tranché par
les législateurs démocrates du maine qui
détiennent la majorité depuis l'automne
une nouvelle loi permet désormais
d'obtenir un avortement sans supervision
de médecins message politique clair
destiné au reste du pays
[Musique]
- ici
dans les prochains mois giuly jenkinson
n'aura plus besoin d'avoir recours aux
médecins par téléconférence sa poursuite
judiciaire contre l'état du maine et
maintenant caduque
cette bataille pourrait reprendre dès la
prochaine élection
tout pourrait basculer à nouveau si les
républicains reprenaient le contrôle de
la législature du maine
[Musique]